Stan Shaughnessy of the Boston Globe the
Red Sox got off the mat to make a brand
new start of it in New York is a recent
column and Dan joins us now Dan how
surprised were you what happened last
night
well you know one thing we need to
remember is there's there's frequently
no carryover and that was something for
folks to take to the stadium tonight is
that 1601 looked great for the Sox but
is there any carryover if the ball if
Sabathia is good and Purcell is not so
yeah it certainly felt like it was all
about New York after the way the thing
ended in Fenway on Saturday and then
right out of the jump under Severine I
had nothing who was oblivious to that
and it brought a starter it'll equip
starter into the game and just let it
get away early which was it was a
jailbreak from that point when did you
realize that San Marino maybe got to the
ballpark laid or got to his you know his
bullpen session late I didn't know about
the lateness until you know mid game or
you know it was being reported I guess
by darling on TV but well the first
pitch of the game Mookie Betts hit it
like 110 miles and out of center field
it was on a warning track and you could
tell they were squaring up everything
and that was through three innings when
it was still a manageable three nothing
game but I was stunned after seeing you
know we've seen Severino it's his
trick-or-treat pitcher he can have
no-hit stuff or he can take you out of
the game early and in a short series or
any playoff series you got to be
prepared for that they were last year
when he spit the bit in the wild-card
game they had him out of there in the
first inning I was stunned that with the
with the you know stable of bullpen arms
that they have out there that they gave
this game away and it's weird to think
of a 16 to 1 game the Yankees could have
done better but when it was still 3 for
nothing if they take care of business
and get into that Boston bullpen it's a
different game so I yeah they just gave
that one away do you think the Red Sox
are the best team well it changes every
day Dan I mean I today I say yes but I
didn't think they were eight days better
than the Yanks I thought that the Hunter
name was a little bit deceiving which is
weird to say because only thing only
like 11 T's and baseball have ever done
as much or more but you know they just
the
American League was really a casteist in
this year you had these tremendously
terrible teams you know hundred loser
teams and the Sox took care of business
against them and they just I think they
were 16 and 3 against Baltimore so and
again we can't punish them for beating
the t's in front of them but it was an
unusual it was no middle class than the
American League this year and the Sox
took took advantage of that but I you
know against the playoff field Boston
was 18 and 21 and the Yankees I think
were 22 and 16 so no I did not think the
Sox were eight K is better than them the
David Price conundrum can you you have
to leave him at home and even if you
leaving him home you got you got roughed
up there you know the other night yeah
yeah I mean you know the this thing
anything's possible you could see him in
a relief role still although it's they
don't have many lefty hitter see he's
not really a specialist and and he's
been so bad in the stadium here I just
thought but I do think your Boston
advances he's in the rotation for the
next round you may get moved to the four
guy or something like that but he will
be one of their starters that they play
Huston do you still feel like there's
this like is there still tension between
the Red Sox and Yankees you know it's
been a long time that since they got
together in the playoffs but did do you
still feel like it's there it's nothing
like it was of course and there's a much
more professional respect and I'll play
Association and all that stuff it's just
Millennials just aren't wired the way
Munson in fiscal or who really hated
each other so you just aren't going to
have that but I do think that you know
they had a little brawl earlier this
year with Joe Kelly was involved in that
was kind of fun and I think that Judge
walking by the clubhouse playing the
music you know was a little bit
provoking and I and I think that Holt's
you know styling on the on the cycle
hitting it off a catcher in the ninth
inning I don't think the Yankees
probably loved that either but when you
get your ass kicked 62 one you really
can't say anything but sometimes people
remember that keep an eye on Sabath you
tonight early because he hates the Red
Sox when they bunt on him and they
should come out of the gate Beth should
should try to push one up the first pace
line right at the start of the game
because Sabathia hates that and I think
they should do it Ron darling also
mentioned that the Red Sox shouldn't
have been swinging on three okay last
night you know with that big advantage
and I thought you know what
these two teams play each other I think
they know what the unwritten rule is we
may not on the outside looking in but he
had a problem with them swinging and
going for homeruns when you're up by
that kind of margin what do you think uh
you know I love Darlie and you know
we're older guys I you know we're all
rich Gossage when it comes to this right
it's like you know don't I think the Sox
took a bag and it's in with ten nothing
lead to I mean there was things going on
it then again but you've got to take
care of that in a playoff series you
can't get all emotional so their job is
to win the game tonight but I'm sure
some of that stuff they weren't wild
about but what can you say when you're
down 16 to one any other drama up there
in New England I saw where the Celtics
might be on the short list for Anthony
Davis Patriots feel like that
everything's getting back to normal here
anything else to write about it's the
pages yeah we're just it's it's a high
Renaissance as you know up in our town
and uh you know those pages got a huge
game Kansas City is Sunday night that's
a big one for them and they expect them
to get where they want to go which is
the AFC Championship game they do every
year
so things have high expectations with
everything that's happened in the
conference and uh Davis I'd that's a
stretch but it's nice to have it talked
about and what about Kyrie
dude he said he wants to resign so it I
know it's just verbal but what do you
make of it
Kyrie says the earth is flat yeah I
don't believe anything comes out of his
mouth but he seems like a nice kid he
said I think he's always messing with us
so that was a weird thing to do in front
of the season ticket holders so great I
hope it's true and there's a lot to
believe in here given the young roster
they have and young coach they have and
the weakness of the conference why
wouldn't you want to stay here so
hopefully that is true but I believe it
when he ups in Gordon Hayward it's green
light he's good to go
we'll go yeah and that you know again
they got to the one game for the
Conference Finals from the NBA files
without their two best players and we've
seen him for a total of five minutes in
regular season games so a lot to look
forward to there and they you know they
should be the best team in the east Dan
thanks for joining us as always have fun
tonight play nice as well well Dan
Shaughnessy
boston globe' combs for more Dan Patrick
show to the
it's channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]